I think most people don't in but I think  the biggest reason most people don't win  is they don't know themselves or they  don't want to believe in what they know  about themselves and I think if you  could figure out who you are you're just  gonna be happier it's not about making a  million dollars a year there's so many  people listening right now that make two  hundred thirty seven thousand dollars a  year and they're miserable and they'd be  so much happier making a buck forty  three from eighty nine doing [ __ ] they  love or they're good at and we just  don't do that more and for what Lance  for like an extra like bike or wine or  better tickets to the Cowboys or Jesse